on election night when donald trump came
out in the early hours of the morning
and said
um i believe we've already won i
we've won as far as i'm concerned he
said i gasped
i gasped i thought oh hell
and there's several things about that
one is
you better if you're the trump team you
better provide
really good fast about that and frankly
what they've provided is not good enough
proof yet
they have been providing uh
some things that sound to me like they
are conspiracy theories unless they've
got a lot of stuff to come i hope that
for their sake they've got a lot of
stuff to come or there are a lot of
reputations that are being trashed
all the time
more than 8 out of 10 trump voters
in the last poll i saw believe donald
trump won the election
and obviously joe biden's voters believe
he won
this seems to me a very perilous moment
for democracy
it's what i just described in chemnitz
on the national
level you saw the same thing
and you've come away with different
conclusions what do you think would be a
responsible way
for the media to talk about this then
because one of the things i've been
trying to do for the last couple weeks
here is i'm saying look
i i don't know exactly what happened i
don't think anyone really knows i do
know
that at about midnight pacific time here
that about eight states that trump had
healthy leads in all stopped voting at
the same exact time
i'm not saying trump won we'll you know
now it's going to go to the courts and
there's all sorts of things happening
but i've at least been trying to to talk
about it
respectfully right so that it allows
people to say okay let the process work
and then at the end if it comes out that
yes did i want trump to win yes
but if if the courts look look at
everything and he doesn't win
then so be it but i think what a lot of
people are frustrated
that eight out of ten you just
referenced i think what they're seeing
is that the media won't even let you
talk about it and that if you talk about
it you're going to be put on a list
and you're going to be labeled a
conspiracy theorist and you're going to
get booted from social media
and the rest of it and that strikes me
as more of a problem maybe than
what actually happened at some point
well
no i i disagree with that i mean i think
the the biggest problem
is if the president doesn't leave the
white house
and he's lost oh well of course if we
get there and he and he has
actually lost his leave of course i mean
you know look
i i'm i'm sympathetic to much of
your argument on this and your point of
view on this but i mean
and i'm by the way i'm particularly
irate about the fact that
there are so many democrats who spent
four years claiming that the american
voting system had been fundamentally
undermined and indeed that the russians
have stolen the 2016 election something
for which they never showed us any
evidence
but they asserted anyway nancy pelosi
literally said that that
it was an illegitimate election i mean
yeah i'm
i'm irate about that i was irate about
it for four years i'm irate about the
fact that these same people now pretend
that there is no such thing as voter
fraud in america
however the onus at this stage is on
donald
trump and his legal team to prove
that he won the election now i have to
say i've i've paid
fairly close attention to this as i say
i mean i but first of all may i say
the thing of going to bed and the result
being different when you wake up is
is not unheard of in elections i mean in
the
brexit vote lots of people went to bed
thinking that
um uh that britain was going to remain
in the european union i remember it very
clearly
and of course then suddenly the results
from sunderland and elsewhere the north
england came through and
whoosh we were out and the same people
woke up the next morning
amazed but that's what happened
sometimes in elections
i do think that donald trump is behaving
reprehensibly at the moment i think that
frankly i am very open for
any and all explanations of voter fraud
as it is going on in america as it has
gone on
i think whoever is president on january
the 20th rather
as a point of absolute urgency
should put together a bipartisan
non-partisan cross-partisan team
to look into voter fraud specifically
mail-in voter fraud in the united states
of america
you cannot have another election after
this one which would be a third in a row
where people didn't believe the results
if they lost
so it seems to me the real point of
urgency this
but on election night when donald trump
came out in the early hours of the
morning and said
um i believe we've already won
we've won as far as i'm concerned he
said i gasped
i gasped i thought oh hell
and there's several things about that
one is
you better if you're the trump team you
better provide
really good fast about that and frankly
what they've provided is not good enough
proof yet
they have been providing uh
some things that sound to me like they
are conspiracy theories unless they've
got a lot of stuff to come i hope that
for their sake they've got a lot of
stuff to come or there are a lot of
reputations that are being trashed
all the time well that's what i've said
from b1 it's like sydney powell she's
either self-immolating in front of us or
she's about to break the greatest story
in
in the history of modern times it's it's
one or the other right
yeah i suspect it's the first
uh and i think the same with rudy
giuliani you
you you just can't give press
conferences talking about dead
venezuelan leaders
and think that the citizenry should
i mean it's not just you shouldn't treat
the citizenry stupidly you should not
mislead people's belief in the most
fundamental thing in our nations
which is that we vote and some people
win and some people lose and you know
who's lost and who's won this is a
really
dangerous thing this is a dangerous
element to be playing with
and and i worry deeply about the
consequences of this
but another thing to point out about
this is
that you know i mean you everyone has to
lose sometimes i remember
michael barone saying this to some
conservative gathering
as one sat many years ago i think when
obama won you know michael brown said
you know you have to lose sometimes um
you know the evidence so far seems to be
that the republican the
nominee for the presidency lost this
time
now here's here's the kicker if i may
say so
yeah for four years
the question one of the questions has
been why is donald trump
not been able to recruit now there have
been some very remarkable people who
have worked for him and i wouldn't
do down any of them i'm thinking of
people i think secretary of state mike
pompeo
um eliot abrams and others there's some
very very serious particularly foreign
policy figures who have worked for him
who i deeply admire
but there has been a question throughout
the trump presidency why can he
not uh appear to get
more people working with him uh
more experienced people working for him
older hands
more trusted figures some non-family
would be nice
uh uh and so on and so forth what is the
explanation and i
you know it's one of those political
questions that ends up answering itself
it's because everyone worried that at
the end of the run
he would pull some crap like this that
was why
that was why i mean i spoke to a lot of
people in recent years
in america and said to them you know an
american friends and said you know
would you consider taking this post why
don't you consider taking that role and
i always noticed that
it was something you know early on and i
would say you know he's got four years
in office
it's not nothing to be whatever position
was being discussed
and i noticed always this reticence i
think neil ferguson on your show
said that there was always this risk
that trump was going to do something or
come down
in a way that was a scandal of nixon of
not only nixonian proportions but that
would make nixon look like you know a
sort of
uh tea party no tea party means
something else yeah that means something
else does
not a british tea party well yeah yeah a
british tea party
yeah i think yeah and and i think
that's um i think that what we are
seeing at the moment
may be the answer to that question i
have seen it once
else in politics in european continental
politics
with a much more minor political figure
who the same question was
why can't people cohere around why don't
people trust
and in the end the answer answered
itself because he was going to in the
end
pull the crazy crap he pulled and
and i i just i think that unless
unless the trump team can very very
swiftly provide evidence that is
very good and persuasive they are
playing with an element
that they should not be playing with and
i think it will
it will deeply diminish the republican
party if it allows it to go on it will
diminish conservatives it will diminish
the millions and millions of decent
american voters who were trying to send
a very distinct message in 2016
who were reviled for four years insulted
for four years called every imaginable
name
for four years it will further
demoralize them and weaken them i
i i hope i hope if he has something it
comes out
yes by the way douglas you know while
i'm obviously sympathetic to
to the campaign and i wanted him to win
i'm completely with you on that it's
like if
if there isn't anything there and they
and they've truly done something here
that was to destroy the system or
completely erode trust or anything else
yeah
then it's almost the most dangerous
thing well i guess it would be the
second most dangerous thing
you know compared to actually rigging
the election so you know
we'll find out over the next couple
weeks if they have if they if the
democrats did actually break the
election then it is indeed one it is the
most appalling crime against american
democracy
and there should be a such a thorough
investigation and so many people going
to prison
it would be the scandal of our lifetimes
but if it isn't the case if it isn't the
case
then it is also a great scandal because
you cannot lie to the citizenry about
this i mean
i'm very i'm very open to the argument
of you know four years ago hillary
clinton didn't really
admit that she lost the election and
spent years pretending she had only lost
the election because of the russians and
something to do with a box on facebook
uh look
i thought that was contemptible i think
hillary clinton was again
playing with fire to do her the one
piece of credit that one can do
at least she didn't actually tunnel into
the oval office and
barricade herself in it after the
election in 2016.
it's the one thing hillary clinton has
going for her if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell